transfert des pêches en faire on y va
bonjour docteur qu'à noël dans le jour
mais vainement
bonjour les enfants
bonjour mesdames justine
il était une fois une femme magnifique
cette femme était aussi la plus gentille
la plus intelligente et la plus
incroyable de tout
non je vous en prie faites pas ça un
jour elle fut tout à coup attaqué par un
monstre
fille a couru à toute vitesse
si le monstre et lui dire à sa belle
année
tu es ma meilleure amie
tu vas rester pour toujours avec moi
je suis en train de produire un lot de
vaccins et le principal ingrédient est
elle je suis de quoi
l'espérance
voilà ce que tu es et je survivrai
comme tout le monde
vous m
c'est quoi ça
autre monde se désintègre
pas vous
qu'est ce qui t'a fait
[Musique]